Hey, Jonathan, finally we are meeting.
There we go. Get unmuted here.
Yeah.
There we go.
I'm still not sure. I mean, is it a good time today?
Oh yeah, yeah, we're good.
Yeah.
Okay, that's great.
Excuse me, but why do I cough?
All right, I see that you know, Kris has declined this meeting. Probably he is busy somewhere else today.
Yeah, he stays involved in who knows what.
Yeah, so is it is Dylan, you know, joining today or is he also out somewhere?
I don't know his current status.
Xbox.
Yes.
That's fine. Otherwise, you know, I was just expecting even more is merrier. If more people can join and we can have a discussion with you as well.
Uh...
We'll see, was he actually on this invite? I don't remember.
If this was sent to Dylan as well.
Mhm.
When we rescheduled, I don't know if you knew.
If he was included on the invite from you guys end.
That's alright.
Yeah.
Just checking it out while we're talking.
Yeah, absolutely. Dylan, Kris, you know, everyone is added there and the invite.
Okay.
But that's all right. I mean, we understand. They may have some other priorities going to come in on their plate at the same time, which is why they may not be able to join. That's all right.
So, these past two to three weeks have been going really, really busy for you as well.
Yeah, we've had a...
Shuffle, gosh, can't talk. Shuffle some schedules around and kind of make some things happen, so.
And I think lately you have been going a lot of on-site, right, to attend some stuff.
Yeah, yeah, a little more last few weeks.
Thank you.
All right. Sir, before we start, thank you, Jonathan. Sir, is there anything from your end before we get it going?
Syrup.
Oh, no, Gagan, I thought you were confirming with Jonathan. Please continue.
Ohh.
All right. So thank you, Team. So officially, welcome to this call. I mean, I know before getting this call started, or while I was waiting to get this started, I was just looking at when is the next call. Will it be happening in another just one or two weeks? But that's fine. We can.
If required, we can schedule that time accordingly or decide accordingly. So team, I'm sharing my screen and let me know once it's visible to you on your screens.
Yes, it is, Gagan.
Yep, I've got it.
Thank you.
So, yeah, of course, we are doing this in the month of May. This presentation will present data for the month of April about Victor. So team, feel free to chairman whatever you think. There's any sort of feedback, any observations you have on any certain point on these slides. We'll be glad to hear from you.
So agenda has not changed. We have highlights, performance analysis, ITBD, CSAT, way forward with innovative technology solutions, AI by design, which Sarah will take care of, and holiday schedule, and of course, recap the reason after this call.
via email along with the minutes of meeting.
Shh.
I've not captured much, but these are some of the, you know, positive highlights thinking about Victor. So, he exceeded his ticket resolve rate in the month of April, and his number of tickets worked remain highest year till date.
Kam.
Well, which I'll show you in the following slides.
Just excuse me for my call. It just started 10 or 15 minutes back. Sorry.
Yeah.
You're good.
He continues to curb on his PTO utilization. What I'm mentioning is because this was previously, I mean, just suddenly, you know, came up as a concern or, you know, a few months back and which he needed to control on so that, you know, he is within his stipulated.
Mhm.
Ohh.
The threshold of PTOs, those are being given to him yearly as well as quarterly basis. So he has very well and very well managed this and he has not taken, you know, much PTO. So I see in the month of April, he just took one on 24th.
And that too, when he had a plan with me and the rest of the team to go out on a trekking. So unfortunately, you know, I could not be a part of that plan, but yeah, so that was important to get away with the team.
I would like to hear from you as well, Jonathan. Overall, I don't know how much time you got to review or observe things, you know, what he's doing on a daily basis, but any observations from your end?
Overall.
Uh, I mean, no, nothing specific. I mean, he just continues to do a good job with us and um...
We actually have one person, another person now, Casey, that was in the office doing, going full remote for the next month or two right now. So that's where it just becomes a shift on our end just to make sure that, hey, we are still communicating within, you know, internally with each other because it's not.
Yeah.
Mm-hmm.
It's not like she's going to be just sitting in the office to know when things come in or schedule things. So we just have to make sure that we're all on the same page, just with internal communication with everybody, including, you know, Victor, we're helping them with Helpdesk and all that kind of stuff. So that's really about the only thing that's kind of shifted on our end, just to kind of be aware of, but
Absolutely, like we're sharing this, and I'm sure I have mentioned Casey's name in my this presentation as well. You know, later on you'll see that. I sometimes forget Casey's a male, right?
Okay.
No, female.
Oh, female, okay. Sure.
Yeah, her name's just been a little bit different.
Okay, KACI.
Yep.
Okay.
All right, thank you. So, moving on to performance analysis in comparison with the previous to previous month, March, I see is a billable utilization touch seventy-eight percent and target was 80%. I was surprised, I mean, why he, you know, could not touch this target, despite, you know, I'll...
You know, I'll show you on the next slide, despite the fact he touched more number of tickets, as I mentioned in the main highlight slide, that till now, year till date, I mean, he touched maximum number of tickets in the month of April. But I believe he's too quick in resolving those things, resolving those issues, whatever comes on his plate.
And, you know, this is, you know, kind of funny. One day I was sitting with him for 15 minutes just to observe him, you know, how he does things. So he says,
Mhm.
You know, I just keep looking at my board all the time, and you know my cursor is on that refresh button. As soon as the ticket comes in, you know, I just assign this to myself so that it, you know, it doesn't go to anywhere else. And this is how, you know, I grab tickets and, you know, start working on them. And sometimes he said,
even before Casey or someone else observes that, oh, the ticket has actually landed, but where did it go? Okay, so Casey confronts with Victor. Victor, did you pick it up that quick? So Victor says, yes, I did pick it up. You know, I just reviewed the ticket. Okay, yeah, blah, blah, blah. This is something I can do it.
Mhm.
And this is how he does it. So I'm impressed with the way he picks up tickets really fast. I mean, unlike, I know, I must not be saying, but some people do have this tendency of, you know, voiding task or let other person look at it and, you know,
put it to his plate so that, you know, I can easily say that, oh, you know, this ticket wasn't signed or taken up by the other person, which is why, you know, I didn't get it. But here, I mean, this is the opposite. So I feel he has hunger over doing things so that, I mean, which is why in your environment is a
plus on top of that. So he's learning a lot of things. So he's getting a procurement work, you know, licensing things, GoDaddy stuff.
working on, yeah, web activities and all that. So he's getting good exposure with technical stuff as well. If we see in the month of April, every week, I mean, he was, you know, close to meeting his target, although he didn't meet it, but 76 in the first, 75 in the second.
Mhm.
85 was a good number. And in the third week from 20 to 24, and in the last week, 74%. In comparison to, if you see in the month of March, it was drastically low, 70, 60, and 58. So he has improved, you know, to a great extent in the month of April.
Yeah.
And I'll show you in the following slides before we move on to the following. Anything from your end, if you observe something different or differently.
No, I was trying to go back and see.
Well, I was trying to pull something up real quick that made me think of when you were going through the scenario.
Um...
We can stop the screen sharing, Gagan. Jonathan, you would like to share it.
I think, uh, I think all that's fine.
Yeah, I think all that's fine. Thing that we have to be careful of, and this goes back to making sure we're up to date with like internal communications with tickets and sometimes like that, because what happens is, and again, I kind of, I know we've kind of stated this before and believe me, I don't have any issues with people working tickets and grabbing things and making sure things are
done. But I just want to make sure that we don't run into any miscommunication or confusion around that, which has happened in the previous instances where I've mentioned to Victor, like, please don't just automatically grab tickets because what happens is with our auto task system, what happens is
If Casey's looking at the unassigned board and she's getting ready to assign a ticket to, you know, person A, but then Victor is already in it. And then as she's trying to assign it, he's already grabbed the ticket and accepted it. The system doesn't refresh fast enough for everything to kind of be in sync like that.
So what happens is she goes trying to sign a ticket to a tag. It's like, oh, this one's already been assigned. She's like, how is it already assigned?
I'm trying to assign it right now and we'll go back and look at it. It's like, oh, Victor took the ticket, which again is great, but what I want to make sure happens is that he's just not taking tickets without the dispatcher.
because that's one of her primary roles, knowing about it. So I want to make sure that things don't just get automatically grabbed. And believe me, we try to keep him busy and stocked up and all that stuff as much as we can. And the other side of it too, I wanted to mention you guys just so you're aware of it too, on our last internal meeting last Friday.
Mmh.
You know, I was encouraging everybody because some scenarios that happened, this isn't specific to Victor, this was just an internal thing to all of our guys, all of our techs, because I feel like we've gotten to a point where...
And again, this kind of goes back to Casey's role too, because we have certain clients, like in the state of Georgia or something like that, that mainly, you know, a couple of techs work on primarily. But if they're tied up and she knows they're already tied up working on other things and an urgent ticket comes in, she may shout out on Teams, hey, everyone, like who can work on this? They put this as an urgent ticket, blah, blah, blah.
Mhm.
The short of it is, although I felt like we've gotten to, is we all like to get in our comfort zones, right? We all know, like, hey, I know how to do this piece. I can do this real quick. But what's happening is that people may not be, all of our techs may not be fully aware or familiar with some of the things some of the newer onboarded clients are doing.
that like Dylan and Green have onboarded and worked with them more primarily. So example would be.
Mhm.
Basically, what I want to get to, what I've encouraged everybody to do, sorry, I'm kind of rambling, is even if you're not sure about how to work on something or what this specific app is or something like that.
Mmh.
Even if you're the only person available that can help, that can at least get on a call with that person or start looking into it, don't be afraid to start that process, start the troubleshooting. You know, a lot of these things work in the same way. It's just a matter of understanding what the person is trying to do.
and where the issue is of the breakdown. So trying to encourage all of us, including Victor as well, like I said, to, hey, just because you're not familiar with how this works or what you're looking for in this situation, don't be afraid to call them because we've all been in those scenarios. We've had to call and help people and help figure things out that we've not seen before.
So just in general, as the team trying to provide IT support, like don't be afraid to try to jump into something that you're not 100% familiar with or even 30% familiar with. Because at that point, because a lot of times some of our texts, oh, this is this issue, you can try X, Y, Z first.
And so we'll even have that to kind of go off on as initial steps to kind of start looking into. So those are the two things, making sure that, you know,
Yeah.
Traffic hot, ticket wise, things don't get moved around without things being known or Victor raising his hand saying, hey, Casey, I can take that ticket or whatever kind of scenario. Plus being able to jump on things that just may not know right off the top.
Mhm.
Oh, this is how you fix it kind of scenarios. So those are the two things.
No, thank you, Jonathan. And you know, that's exactly what we want. Whenever you observe anything that needs attention or, you know, be it specifically for Victor or for the entire team, I think that is really appreciated. And yeah, this was told to Victor Evan previously, and I'm sure.
You know, he is taking care of this, and if it is not, if there is still some room of improvement, so he will work on this, that he works in a collaboration with Casey, whatever, I mean, so that he does not pick tickets on his own.
So he can let Casey know that there's a ticket on the board, and this is something he can work on, and so that this can be assigned to him.
Yeah. I mean, just as simple, just, I mean, it's, it can even be just as simple as him sending a message to Casey, like from him to her and the Team chat or something to be like, hey, saw this command, gonna go ahead and grab it or work in this ticket or whatever. So now she knows, like she don't have to.
Yeah.
Okay.
try to, she can refresh the screen, see if it goes away, or he can say, hey, you can move this one to me. I'm already looking at it. Then that way she can assign it to Victor from the ticket board aspect, even though he may have already started troubleshooting on it. So those are the scenarios that I would suggest.
Sure, thank you. Absolutely. And apart from that, that's my clarity question, you know, from you. In order to meet his utilization, so at ITBD, so recently we have restructured our billable targets, so that is 80%. But I see that despite the fact, although...
Even when he does not discuss, you know, with Casey or, you know, grabs tickets on his own, I was considering that's a good thing. But yeah, from your standpoint, you know, yes, absolutely. So Casey is specifically hired for this position. So, you know, she must assign ticket.
Mhm.
Would he be able to get enough tickets or, you know, stuff on his plate so that he meets his billable number to 80%? Or what should be the realistic number that you expect out of him to meet the productivity time target?
No, I still think 80% is the right point.
Especially going based off this, looking at April, definitely, like you said, definitely a lot closer to that mark versus what was going on in March.
Yeah.
So...
Because if I see the previous month, just a moment.
Let me ensure, and you know, share my the other screen my rough sheet to you, so I can we can review the previous months.
I hope my sheet is visible to everyone.
Okay, yeah.
So this is my rough calculation. I mean, a raw calculation, I would say. So this month, I mean, it was very closed 78% in the month of April. And so in the month of March, it was 69%.
And previous to that, in the month of February, it was again 69 percent. And in the month of January, he was at 96 percent.
Yeah.
Okay.
But generally was the only one exception. But if I consistently look at it, he was, he's between 60 to 70 or close to that. So if he's, if he's struggling to meet, I mean, despite the fact, I mean, whether he touches, you know, 300 plus tickets or 220 or 250, 242.
Right.
That remains the average number of tickets he receives on a monthly basis.
Okay.
So, there is something, I mean, there's a, you know, gradual inflow of tickets which he manages, or or the kind of the type of ticket that he receives on daily, weekly, and monthly basis, either.
You know, the major, I think the maximum number is service request instead of incidents. Incidents usually do take time. It may take 20 to 25 or maybe 30 minutes, but when he receives a service request, let's say, give me a password. I forgot my password so he can quickly, I mean,
jump on to 80, reset the password, gives that to the user. So I think it does not take more than 15 minutes. So if you review, I mean, you can do it internally, or you can give me the data if you review, because I do not have access to any tools.
Mmh.
Let me unshare my screen and share back the presentation. I had worked with one of my one of our clients on this particular thing. You know, that was about reference of alerts, so that we understand what sort of alerts they are receiving, they have received in past.
three months, one quarter to two quarters, so that we can eliminate work effectively, so that we can eliminate those recurring alerts coming on their board, you know, on a daily basis.
But so in this particular scenario, do you know exactly what percentage of service requests, you know, land on the board or what percentage of incident tickets or alert tickets that he works on?
For the most part, I will say that everything that comes into our unassigned.
Bored.
Mhm.
is usually more customer facing. There still are a couple things that go into that about like maybe some screenshot verifications, like on some backups and some very minor, well, not minor, but non customer facing things like end user kind of deal.
But for the most part, like 90% of this on the unassigned board is more customer facing like end user troubleshooting or.
A server going offline or something like that, so...
Most of the time, all the other stuff goes into a separate, like, alert queue.
Yeah, so I'm dividing.
that we have. So if he's doing stuff from unassigned, it should be more true like customer end issues.
Yeah, thank you. So I divided a customer facing into two parts. One is incidents and service requests. So both of these are customer facing.
The user may call in. I'm sorry for my bad throat.
Oh, you're good.
Thanks, Tom.
Yeah, so the user may call in to, you know, for any kind of request, maybe he needs to, or he or she needs to map a printer to the machine or map a drive to the machine, or they need access to some folder, or they need to get a password reset. So these are really, you know, small tickets, but if...
We talk about customer-facing incidents that maybe my Outlook is not working, my computer is running very slow, or this particular application is, you know, is causing some problem, so incident tickets always supersede service requests when it comes to...
time spent. So, which is why I was asking if Casey continues to assign ticket, which I totally advocate that, but what should be the realistic target? If you see it's 80%, I personally feel, you know, there has been a challenge.
I mean, if that needs to be addressed, Sarah, your point, your inputs would also be welcome.
Thanks, Jonathan. Thank you for the feedback. Gagan, please connect with Victor. Ensure that whenever he is looking for tickets, if he do not have enough ticket, he should share it with Casey. Not possible, then he can reach out to Jonathan.
If you can suggest something.
And we can move ahead. 80% is the good target that Jonathan has also applied. Jonathan, I'm really sorry. I have to be in the another meeting. Two things from my end, Gagan, if that's okay, we can stop the screen sharing for a moment. We have not yet received the CSAT for Victor for the last three months.
Yeah.
So, Gagan will resend the surveys for Victor, so that you can share your feedback, as it will be a part of the scorecard. Second, I'll...
I don't think I've gotten that either.
Sir, I'm not sure whether you're aware or not. So I had, you know, checked with Kris and he said he did receive the service, but I mean, previously it was sent to Jonathan as well. I'm sure for March or maybe for April, Jonathan, you must have received as well. It does not say CSAT, but feedback.
I.
If...
For the month of...
S.
for the month of April or March. So Kris said he was trying to fill the survey, but it did not allow him to. So our team, GPS team is working with Kris on that.
Okay.
We tested. I mean, it worked good for myself and the Team GPS did work on the other one. So that test was successful. We just need to, you know, close this with a Kris that he's able to, you know, fill it now successfully.
So Gagan, Kris has already sent us the BHD service. It's for the Dedicated Services. So probably you can send that one out. And Jonathan, I will also share the link after the call. We have our annual MSP event that's building.
Yeah.
Live that's happening on August 3rd to August 5th, New Jersey, Hyatt Regency, and this time we are taking our partners to.
New York Stock Exchange. So for our partners specifically, we have the Dedicated offer where you can get one partner free of cost. So let me bring it up on the screen real quick. If that's okay with you.
Oh, wow.
Thank you, Gagan. We can.
Jonathan, I'm sorry. Do you have a few extra minutes? I'm in to to review, you know, a few more things.
Kip.
Yeah, yeah, well, I'm good.
Thank you.
Sure. So this is what I was talking about, Jonathan. I will also share the information with Kris and with the rest of the team too. But just to bring you up to the speed, this is the event that's happening from August 3rd to August 5th. So this time on the last day of the event, we are taking our partners to New York Stock Exchange, specifically for the After Hours party.
Mhm.
That's one great gets meeting. Talking about the event, what the event is all about. You will have more than 550 plus attendees, that 70 plus channel influencers. Primarily, we'll be discussing about the tools, the templates, which we have updated for our partners, which we have created internally. In addition to this, the focus, the agenda for.
Kour.
Similarly, we have for day two and day three. I'll send you the links over an email so that you can go through the details. And I'll put a code so that you can go ahead and get one complimentary ticket free of cost. So current price of the tickets is 1495.
And if there is any clarity required, I'm just a text away. You can always drop me a text and I'll be glad to schedule a separate call with you. Last but not the least, I have mentioned the Q1 NPS survey link in the chat. So this is not for Victor. This is the overall services which you have been receiving from IT by Design.
That's where we'll be looking forward for your feedback. Line and 10 are for the promoters. If there is anything where you would like us to focus on, feel free to do so. Rest, I'm sorry guys, I need to jump on a different meeting, but thank you for your candid feedback, Jonathan. We'll work on the action item shared.
Awesome, thank you.
Thank you.
Thank you, Sarbjeet. As well, thank you. I will be sharing my screen. I hope that is visible to you again.
Take care.
Yeah.
All right, thank you. So just a moment. Yeah, so moving on to from time, productivity time to number of tickets, ticket resolve rate, the number of tickets he worked on. So we can see there's a gradual improvement. In the month of April, so he...
Total number of tickets he worked on were 303, out of which he was able to complete or resolve 274. Well, in the month of, whereas in the month of March, it was 226 he worked on, out of which he was able to complete 206.
There was, yeah, there's a little bit, I would say.
Ohh.
Yeah, although the number of tickets voided and closed were less, but his ticket resolve rate was still, I mean, in the March, in the month of March, it was 91.15% and the April, it remained 90.43%.
So I can see a daily average in the month of April remained 16.13 tickets a day, you know, which is higher than March versus 12.6. Yeah.
Any comments, any feedback on this?
No, I don't think so at the moment.
Okay, thank you. So we already discussed that, so you know, I'll shoot this survey again. And going forward, as we discussed previously, if Kris is busy on external stuff, clients and everything, should we direct this survey to you, continue to direct this to you, survey about Victor?
I would say so, yeah. Just so you guys get the information.
Okay, like.
Okay, thank you. I'll show the service to you. Thank you. And yeah, way forward. Again, continue to support Victor and encourage him to upscale. And I mean, nothing much has changed. And you know, this is what I was requesting earlier. So providing auto task access.
would help us gauge his productivity on real-time basis. If this is still feasible, you may consider that. And yeah, this is for me to assist and support Victor with projects and advanced tasks as if and as he gets. And of course, the other.
You know, thing that we always, you know, focus is on, you know, keep team always feel like they work, they work with family, just sit together, dine on a weekend, or sometimes, you know, take them out for lunch or dinner.
Mhm.
Yeah, so our quarterly, you know, get together is also, I mean, organized by sometimes, you know, our company organization, because we promote this, you know, which we call ESAT, employee satisfaction.
That is it from our end. Optional holidays is one thing. So he has already consumed his Holi festival. That was in the month of March and the second one is pending in November. However, we will definitely let you know much in advance, at least three to four weeks in advance, if there is any sort of business requirements on this specific day.
you can let us know and we'll speak to Victor if we can accommodate on that particular day and take a day off later, sometime on a later day. And these composite holidays, the remaining ones can be marked on this calendar. However, same thing, if there's any kind of requirement.
You can let us know.
Team GPS, we have already discussed waste time, so please do let us know if there's any sort of tool that is meeting your requirement on these features. You can scan this QR code and team will be right there to give you a demo.
All right.
Service is not here on this, but he has better insights. So this is AI by design, ITBD initiative on AI stuff because we know that market is changing drastically day by day, much faster than we can think of. So which is why our focus is on.
various different agents and tools and services based on AI. We'll give you more information on it. I can let our customer experience team to share more details over email as well, so that if you're interested on any of these things that you think maybe you're working on something else side by side.
But if you think any of these may help in your environment, we'll be glad to assist you with that.
That is it. Thank you for spending your extra time with us. I mean, that was a good, meaningful discussion, communication, and of course, feedback and insight, hearing from you. Evan, thank you for joining this call. Anything, anything from your end?
Yeah, I'm sorry for joining this. I made a little late, Jonathan, but I think, as Gagan is saying, I'm sure there are some areas of improvement or some, you know, feedback for Victor. That's what I've heard, and maybe I'm wrong, but don't worry, we will definitely work on it.
So you'll see the improvement. Rest of good. Thank you.
Yeah, thank you. So thank you, Jonathan, for joining in. And thank you, Kevin. So we'll meet again. I think the next meeting is I don't have calendar, you know, up in front of me. Well, I think that is in next two weeks, possibly. So we'll meet again. And if you think that is too early, Jonathan, do let us know and we can
Kip.
Reschedule, we can move, you know, a few days, you know, later, maybe, depending upon, you know, convenience at your end and our end. OK.
Sounds good.
All right, thank you as well. Share the meeting minutes of this meeting after this call. And please do share your feedback, or I mean, you can speak to Kris as well. If you receive the survey, I mean, he can fill it up and going forward, will be directing those monthly service to you.
about Victor. However, NPS, which is quarterly for the company, as Sarah said, there will still be directed to Kris because it is not only about Victor. NPS is about overall ITBD services that you have opted for. I know you.
Okay.
I mean, in a way to take those as a solution is up to for NOG services as well, apart from Victor and the Team GPS as well. And one more thing, Jonathan, we did not hear from Amy. If you get to, I mean, I know you might have some internal meetings as well.
Mhm.
So if you get a chance, you can inform Amy that previously, whatever changes she intended to have in Team GPS, so our team has implemented those changes. So they just want Amy to review those. And if she still think something is not working or...
needs to work as per her expectation. So, you know, now in this particular version, they can make required changes. So those are possible. So we are, so Team is awaiting her feedback. Okay.
Okay.
Okay, I'll send her a message.
All right, so thank you very much. And that is coming over from my end. And thank you, team. We'll meet again with some more positive updates. Thank you.
Awesome. Thank you both.
Yep. Thank you. Bye bye.
Bye.